hello everybody and welcome to part 11
of my resident evil village gameplay
where
last episode i made a lot of mistakes
uh it's like i i really played when i
was way too tired and forgot that i was
playing
the survival horror and i wasted a lot
of [ __ ] and i didn't read and it was a
bad time
but i think we're gonna be okay i've
only died twice i'm pretty sure in the
entire game once because of lady d
and the other time because i didn't know
what to do about the acid rain i'm not
super concerned
but i did just uh before i started
recording run back through the
heisenberg area because i knew that i
had never really explored it i just
ran through it another open area at the
end because all the
zombies or whatever was spawning so we
did get
it's still not looking pretty some
sniper ammo
which is handy and a couple more things
to sell
ways to pass the time you got new stuff
he does not um
but we can we can buy some things i
think uh we got a large crystal
vivian knight i i don't need the money
i'm fine
and i think i'm gonna sell all this [ __ ]
because i did actually get everything
we need for that so i have unlocked
every single recipe which feels good
um i can't upgrade anything securing
goods is more
we will do anything anything sniper ammo
and we will do handgun ammo
i don't know that i need that much but
i can still get more but my thought is
why not um okay so then if we have a
look at
have a wonderful adventure thank you sir
you know we'll just do some more tetris
work i could probably get some more now
i've got tons of mines i just haven't
been using the mines i've not used them
once because i like don't entirely know
how they work it's like i'm afraid of
them i'm like but i haven't used them
what if they hurt me i don't know what
they're gonna do
so i just haven't even tried um so right
now we only have
a lot of handgun ammo we have sniper
ammo so let me make sure that i put that
put that one there for now and then this
one we're gonna put over
here and that's how it looks right now
uh let's equip the mines let's start
using mines you know
it's about time i've been afraid of them
and then i will make sure that this is
loaded
on both counts beautiful
i think it's gonna be okay i also
um just stopped using the handgun at a
certain point because i don't like it
obvious reasons it's nowhere near as
good as any other weapon
so i have so much ammo for it because i
don't want to use it and i'd prefer to
use anything else but i don't know i've
just not been at a point
really where i've i've been worried
about ammo yet
um i run on the assumption that it will
give me more
ammo for the magnum in the shotgun
pretty quickly and i feel like we'll be
okay
but i guess we'll [ __ ] see i don't
know i made some goddamn mistakes out
here
at autos mill
it's my bad who who is doing this all
over this
[ __ ] town where the [ __ ] did that
come from
is he behind me
where the [ __ ]
mate buddy i have so many handgun
bullets ready for you wherever the [ __ ]
you off
are these the birds i can shoot i should
try it
lykan my my good friend the lykan
that's interesting okay well
whatever the [ __ ] all of this is let's
just
take the higher ground at first shall we
just
see what we can bye
[Applause]
yeah but where are you though okay
oh okay you're everywhere
and you aren't slow but i have so much
[ __ ] ammo
that let's just shoot you right in the
feet
who [ __ ] cares me i got
i got time i didn't need a herb cause
some of you drop bullets please they'll
be sick
i'm just gonna shoot frantically
waste the only hammer that i have left
really
it's fine it's all fine
okay mate come at me then let's dance
let's dance you stupid [ __ ]
i missed two i don't care i don't care
we can miss shots with these it's fine
it's not a problem
well that was a headshot so was that i
think
you're still alive mate
i don't know that you'll recover from
that one um is there another one
no oh he's there yeah
okay it's fine
we will take gunpowder thank you we will
[ __ ] i need rusted scrap we could also
do that
i'll wait and see um all right
this is the downside of these open areas
is that it doesn't tell me
if things are blue or red so truthfully
i don't know
if there are things for me to loot
all right you big angry [ __ ]
there's multiple [ __ ] these big angry
[ __ ]
rude i thought you'd die before you got
there by being perfectly honest
great metal scrap baby oh two of them
okay probably should have blocked that
one
okay there are still more
oh oh there is an achievement for that
hang on let me just craft this [ __ ]
oh baby i appreciate you
there's an achievement for shooting an
arrow out of this guy
that's gonna be really hard unless i do
it with a shotgun but i'm not i'm not in
a position to be doing that [ __ ] right
now
excuse me i just need to fix my
inventory real quick if you could just
wait a second look how quickly we run
through the ammo
i'm making more mistakes um
but i also think i'll be fine i'm not
i'm not worried right now
beautiful i could not possibly go any
further without organizing this that
would be embarrassing for everybody
so we're just not going to do it
we'll leave it at that do i want to try
to shoot this dude's arrow out of the
sky
with a handgun the answer
is probably not
i tried he just [ __ ] hit me no we're
not we're not gonna let you get away
with this mate i'm sorry
that's like a reload save type thing is
there still more than just him though
i'm not sure sounds like there are and
there's a box there which i'm happy to
see
beautiful ah hello
oh did i get it i did i got it
isn't there an achievement for that you
[ __ ]
come on now oh i missed that one
ah i tried to get it again
this isn't worth it i should not be
doing this right now if i missed it then
who cares we'll take the l this is not a
good use of
of the situation that i am in right now
all right bud am i gonna be able to get
to these big boys
i don't need your [ __ ] money
um let's take a look
ah could have missed that
okay
i don't think i can get to the higher
ones sadly
yes please
yeah i don't seem to be able to get to
him it's bloody devastating
what if they drop good things i just
can't get bloody
any of it can i all right
we're gonna leave it for now we're gonna
leave it
where was it where hat
okay i guess it was there
i don't love that me
okay that's concerning
somebody's going to show up
and try to ruin my day out here that's
what i suspect
and i need to stop being afraid of the
minds just because i don't know what
they do
or if they will hurt me or their area or
whatever
it's not reasonable we can craft
still no i need gunpowder
sorry we'll find it
okay okay
[Applause]
somebody's grumpy and i'm not sure where
they are
but i know that they are around and they
are grumpy
oh i thought he was gonna keep missing
[ __ ] hell okay there's a few of you
that might hurt those two
maybe did it get him
oh did you move others two of you okay
whoa who even [ __ ] hit me that time
who did that was that you
over here you [ __ ]
that's his head i'm gonna get you as
well
i shot it again
i swear there's an achievement for that
oh
don't know who that was supposed to be
for
we are now out of chem fluid
but i can crop that too i'm not worried
all right
okay
stop dropping money you [ __ ] jerks
uh okay
we should crop some prostate med
still need the gunpowder
it's fine onward
i say thank you
we'll take that also this is like a real
fortified
[ __ ] lichen setup they've got out
here
it was very organized
beautiful
okay music i hear ya i hear
that you are happening
i'm aware of music
swelling right now
i hear it
and don't love it
okay maybe it's just um
for me to have fun you're just uh trying
to bring good vibes
it's you clearly you have to climb up
the ladder ethan you [ __ ] idiot
god useless piece of [ __ ]
useless man thing
or it could be from here oh oh oh don't
mind if i do wherever that was excuse me
just back at it
well maybe this is how we get up
it's gonna break or something didn't
um okay who made a noise okay
there you go okay see i know that i
could just snipe them
right oh my god that's a lot of noise
but i don't think that i want to
i didn't get him oh hello
i didn't expect that from you
and i tried to god that one and failed
because i've been doing it
so infrequently
thank you thank you thank you for all of
this both of you all lovely thank you
thank god
yeah did i get it right oh push them
away oh let me do that
oh cool
all right and push you away
turns out it's pretty helpful actually
to do that
and then no less stress so we'll just do
that again
do that again and shoot you in the face
right i get you gun powder you little
attention
push seeker away shoot you in the face
beautiful
okay great
oh we've still got mates left all right
let's do this one jump down then go on
[Applause]
boom good day sir oh they still got up
damn it hang on hang on i can use a mine
do i throw the mines
no i just put them down did it hurt me
though did it hurt me
i don't know this is a good time to find
out though i think
i don't think it did this
actually happening here
feels um like a huge positive for me
because i'm like basically just farming
so
it's actually kind of wonderful
all that i was worried about has pretty
quickly become alleviated
um even if i've been very wasteful with
handgun emma but i had so [ __ ] much
that who gives a [ __ ]
okay beautiful
thank you all for joining me today
you're
really helping me out really helping me
out this is great
feeling a lot more confident than i was
beautiful
okay uh i'm still gonna go with shotgun
i think
and the mines i still did not really
test that as well as i
necessarily should have but
maybe now i'll be less afraid of using
them
um okay i'm gonna slot the shotgun
back over here okay well we can put it
here and then we'll put this
over here did i just i did just not even
go to the shotgun that's what i just did
great there you go shotgun
okay beautiful
huge improvements across the board
uh where was that ladder there it is
i don't need all this money that you
keep giving me
but i suspect that i only have as much
money as i do because i keep clearing
rooms
anyway
is it trying to tell me that i have to
do both in a set amount of time or what
nope seems like i'll just be able to
walk through it
cool
thank you why was it so slow was that
loading
unclear i also probably should have
looked through that area for any glinty
things but
it's fine we will be
okay
okay it sure is now it's just i'm
getting suspicious about the amount of
stuff
that the video game was giving me now
i'm just scared
okay thanks for that
appreciate it
okay
cool
doing pretty good
hmm these castle vibes do go hard
they do be going hard i should have shot
the birds damn it also yeah why didn't i
get that achievement
i swear there was an achievement for um
flying crows breakable window flaming at
her out of the sky
oh it doesn't count as a close combat
weapon mayhaps
fair okay
this feels like helms deep this must be
their den
yeah it's pretty helms deepie some real
lord of the rings vibes in here
all right lads
[Applause]
probably wasted that one just one minute
and just missing every shot on this guy
are they behind me as well it sounds
like they might be
oh no they're not oh there is okay
[ __ ] you bloody wanker you can't
just come in and do that to me
all right [ __ ] off would you
do that let's do shotgun because we can
hit
multiple at once from behind huh
you're a prick you're also a prick
that's two missed
now missing hurts so much more where are
right where are we
they dropped so much useful [ __ ] you
know
still not quite where i want to be
though just have a mind
mind for you sir
why not you know why not
i don't really want to use this is all
oh good dodge but unfortunate for me
there's a [ __ ] lot of you
that's for sure but i think i'll be able
to craft more now with what these guys
are dropping
so there are more of them
and i should be using those probably
with lettuce just do a whole lot more of
that
and we could always use one of those
nobody mind me don't worry about it it's
cool
important stuff but making it happen
let's rotate that and i'm gonna go back
to equipping
the pipe bombs
beautiful
all right
no trying to jump down there and failed
so let's go
pipe bomb
you sir just got very murdered
you can also get murdered
both of you do they both die no
somebody's still out here
being alive all right how's that
how's that how's that for you is that
good give me your chem fluid
yeah oh somebody's moved and is upset
beautiful
who is it where i oh my god holy [ __ ] i
didn't see you
alright king i see you now i'm sorry
that i missed you
that whole time
oh see everybody who was telling me that
i should have changed my shotgun i
missed the old shotgun i regret it i
really regret it
because they both take it's two bullets
no matter what
you know what i'm saying
[Applause]
thank you for that all right he's
[ __ ] next
you're exhausting and i wish i had oh no
i just wish i had a mealy weapon
i do i have the [ __ ] knife i'm just
not using the knife
a lana could have used the knife on them
this whole time though it probably
doesn't do
very much damage does it
maybe that's what the um the achievement
where are you
on top of me for the uh the wind the the
knocking the thing out of the thing is
for
okay buddy
[ __ ] missed again
i thought i dodged that too i mean i
clipped him it's fine
reload
it's actually very easy to just let them
come for you
i really could have been doing that this
whole time another one
all right mate because you don't have to
time it well
that seems like it should have worked
i'll admit that that one felt a bit
unfair
thank you there's still more
you [ __ ] up assistant where are
you
i think there are more explosive barrels
somewhere though too
you can maybe kite them to the splosies
i'm not sure
[ __ ] hell man there are a lot of you
in here
does it want me to keep killing him i
assume it does
oh that's that was good actually let's
do that again
it's well placed all right
uh we will move you down and we will
equip
you shortcut
and then just put another mine down just
another poorly placed mine
help me out
[Applause]
you need another one or are you dead i
think you did
that was his face
still
my god all right thank you for all of
this
good sirs appreciate
all of this
i don't feel like i should leave but i
don't know if maybe that what's trying
to tell me that they're just gonna keep
coming but then i don't know
i don't know man i feel like i should
wait
there are more that i just can't see
let's go up this way
or is this where i came from oh it is
where are you bud hello hi mister
cool
fading out no
hmm
i think that it is actually done and the
sounds are just
trying to scam me at this point is
what's happening
don't mind if i do
because i could have been using the uh
explosives but i
want to save those for any big boys that
show up so
it was in the explosive rounds all right
could have gone better
um my aim is definitely a bit panicky
from my own good here
hello lads do i have any more let's just
put that here
it is pretty handy i'll tell you that
much
even if i'm using them poorly all right
bud
oh somebody's trying to fire around me
in the face again i see
that's not very nice of whoever that is
it's you sir
all right
are you larger than normal oh i walked
into it
goddammit that's a shame
all right um why don't we just snipe him
since he's so far away
they may also only take one hit from a
sniper rifle which means
oh [ __ ] it's probably better to use on
them oh hang on hang on we got a big boy
so we want to get out
the thrower
this one which we will equip here for
now
and we will do this
and we'll just do that a couple of times
and it should be all right
everybody's just gonna die and it's
gonna be okay
find my logic one more hang on just let
me reload
it's my last one and then i think that
should be everyone
hey not that i need money
i need things beautiful
okay got it
and that's it all right
should probably do a first aid med as
wasteful as it feels
we're gonna do one of those and then
these okay
it's all right
um yeah i wonder if i should be using
the sniper rifle on the likens more it
just doesn't feel like a good idea
because they're really
um
far away can i combine this stuff
because can't you hold more than one at
a time why do i have them in threesome
whatever
who cares just make it tidy
you know and then we come over here and
we do that
and we are good to go
we have sniper rifle ammo
one mine for some reason and
you can be reloaded as well
great feeling okay
that was a lot of combat so my guess is
it's probably going to give me a break
from combat for a bit also did i check
if that was all clear it was
wunderbar magnum ammo
i wasn't sure how much i would get i
actually assumed that i would get plenty
of magnum ammo until
uh people in comments told me that i
should have been conserving it more i
was like but i'll just get more
i still feel like it's probably gonna
give me more than
than those comments would indicate
surely did i get everything in that room
this is important okay i can't you can't
be
all right
okay we don't have everything in this
weird c-section
yeah is what it's telling me
okay cool
yeah i am
blue wb
go back to equipping the
handgun
also why don't we just reload
the magnum just in case
and then we will have the handgun out
right now
beautiful and then we're gonna craft um
i think maybe
maybe no i'm gonna leave it
hello my friend
okay um
somebody in here is grumpy and it
doesn't sound like heisenberg
but what do i know
i thought it was a cinematic this is
very odd why are you doing me like this
what's happening here am i supposed to
be looking through
this is gonna be some kind of orgy some
kind of
this is gonna be like a sex yeah
like some kind of sex orgy is what's
happening
here i believe oh hello you climb a
divine
okay well um i'm gonna leave you guys to
it have a good time don't let me
slow your roll [ __ ] hell this is too
much ammo the king's orders have finally
arrived
it is most vexing that me must abandon
the border stronghold to those heretics
if i had but a little more time i know i
might be able to turn the tides of this
battle
nay i should not put on as it is my
curiosity that ties me to this place
there are a number of ruins in the
vicinity which the locals say are very
ancient the ceremony site with four
giant statues the caves with the murals
carved on the walls the stone plinth
that they call the giants chalice where
did the people who built them come from
where did they go they'd ask me that we
must abandon this place without maui
okay cool neat don't mind if i do
that's that letter all right
let's do a nice little save right here
and um we're doing okay
we're doing all right i can craft one
alright i'm still not okay
okay
this is a very wet game
game's just got a lot of this looks like
it's going to be a place where i have to
fight someone
um just a lot of cool shiny surfaces
excuse me i know that you've done
something dramatic but um
oh yes oh the biggest big boy is here
the biggest boys they call him
so oh [ __ ] did you get me right right
there i feel like i should use the
magnum
so we want to do that and then we're
gonna
probably just equip you for now i think
maybe
i've locked myself in a corner here and
need to run
am i
i thought i'd stun him alaska did not
i did i just [ __ ] missed that you son
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] i might have
um all right big boy
we can oh [ __ ] again we can certainly
one hit kill the lichens
from [ __ ] this is not good
oh okay oh what are you doing then mate
from this kind of distance so
okay cool i love that for you
i like this guy though nope
i keep putting myself in a corner
and it's not great for me
did you just bring in more of them is
that what you're doing where are you
going are you more your mates where are
you oh they
i just don't know that you should be
allowed to move that fast you know what
i'm saying
no i'm ages away oh [ __ ] there was ammo
there oh my god he's right there i
thought that was a pole
jesus okay excuse me buddy
i you really just keep [ __ ] locking
me in corners there's lots of loot in
here though
cool pipe bombs and [ __ ]
okay he's doing that again
again alana god keep making the same
mistakes it's your own fault at a
certain point
okay uh i don't feel good about
what i have equipped right now um
i just want to get one off on you just
one
would be really cool just one
how am i on health probably should take
it
okay and then we're gonna equip this to
that top slot
what yeah oh that yep reload that
and the same [ __ ] thing again you
predictable sack of [ __ ] where is he
where is he why can't i see him
whenever i can't see the giantess man of
all time i'm very concerned
oh ethan oh ethan oh my god
okay she's just reloading buddy
chill out for one [ __ ] second dude
[ __ ] it's a flashbang anyway who cares
oh yeah pull your boys in we'll [ __ ]
kill them
they're all right yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right
you're the strongest man i've ever met
run a lot of run a lot of run a lot yeah
finally
[Laughter]
i i do like you though i don't want you
to have to go out like this i think
you're very cute
i'm not sure why you're doing that to
like is that supposed to
oh my god
that's why you're doing that i see
okay cool great
take that thank you
[ __ ] hell oh i'm very close to him
he's very close
i don't know that he was that close
people keep asking me what the other
people in these hotel rooms uh adjacent
to me must think and i keep being like i
don't think they can hear me
i think they might be able to hear me on
this one the big jump you've got there
my boy
my lad your big jumpy boy
okay hang on i need to change some
equipment we ran out of [ __ ] that's
useful for this
so i'm gonna go pipe bombs at the bottom
here
because that's out right
yeah yeah
oh my god i made a mistake i was just
trying to do yes that
oh my god okay
let's pipe on my boy a couple of times
just hype for me
pipe on me situation out here oh [ __ ]
i'm still over there somewhere aren't
you mate oh did i just
oh oh my god
hello my friend i did not see you
because i don't made it the smoke
that was my fault where are you where
have you gone
how do i keep losing the largest man to
ever have lived
you hate polls though you really hate
falls oh he got me anyway
he got me anyway ethan could we like
pick up the pace just a
tiny bit my dude like just even the tiny
slight little where the [ __ ] are you
stop hi oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i hate it when he throw an entire pole
at me also i just dodged that in real
life i went
to watch out for
i know you're here in your lodge
do you get him okay
each yeah nailed it
ethan again just so fast with the
with the wit yeah
you're really telling them okay
that was all right you know worse things
have happened to me
um okay so what's the situation
yeah we're okay we're in we're in fine
shape
shame that i'm pretty sure i missed the
magnum shot but hey
it happens i also just
got so bad at shooters with the
controller in recent years
um because of playing too much on pc
okay let's just
you know what we're just gonna do that
even if that just seems very weird you
can put you
down the bottom here single mine to
clean you out
everybody's reloaded okay and we've
cleared the room
we've cleared the room what's all this
what
somewhere i've not been i hope
because that would be devastating okay
ooh
frame ready but this is pretty my my
wait are these all gonna be things i can
shoot every single one of these
are you kidding
this is too many am i gonna get rich in
here
they're everywhere what the [ __ ]
up there oh my god it's raining crystal
that means i'm gonna get a new gun
doesn't it it also obviously fits the
environment if we're being honest
i think there's still one that i miss
over here somewhere right there's one
that i missed a shot on
there
where are you bud you're like here
somewhere ish
where is it is on the tip or something
or something
thank you thank you thank you thank you
shiny boy oh
you too i have the most gamer face right
now
that where is it
shiny
how the boy did it go have i done this i
can't believe you've done this
that's not all of them oh it is
unless the shiny boys don't count
i think i maybe did get them all
just i did wonderful okay
that's pretty i like that cool little
white crystal cave very nice
all right that's good too
is it bloody oath
this as well excellent
okay cool great yeah for me
not ominous at all we should craft
more first no alana you keep going to
craft mines when that is not what we
want
beautiful
oh the torso of my child as it were
something terrible is going to happen
the minute i try to grab this so
hey queen i miss you so [ __ ] much
dude
oh what
you're the real deal ethan well done
thank you hiding [ __ ] i'm not letting
you get out of this
cool your jets just a little bit more
and you're all wrapped up i'll lend you
a hand
so in exchange in exchange what
first of all come to me put all the
flasks in the altar
and i'm sure you'll figure the rest out
yeah is the twist here that i'm helping
them
goddamn it is that what's actually
happening am i helping them by doing
everything that i'm doing because that's
sort of what it feels like
take the floss to the altars it's a new
oh i don't mind if i do
yes i would like the treacher under the
stronghold thank you sir
giggly almost plate what here
oh says this batwoman oh my god is that
actually supposed to be my baby mayhaps
hmm how's this room beautiful
[ __ ] dunsky's mate okay
out we go
i still haven't met um
lady miranda who i'm assuming
will turn into some kind of giant
tentacle
woman because this is just taking me
right back here um
at some point towards the end of the
game
but yeah i mean we know that everyone in
the town is doing whatever they're doing
for her not even necessarily because
they're evil themselves
it's an interesting character study it's
more so because they
need her approval for whatever [ __ ]
reason i feel like i should investigate
this even if it's not where it wants me
to go right now
what are you what is this have i been
here
i have not cool
yeah they keep talking about these cat
owls
scars from pneumonia oh me too dude me
too
oh well oh he turned into a like and i
was gonna say maybe that makes me immune
to this weird cat hour torture but i
would just turn into a like him
death
oh that's lady d alcina dimitrisk
maybe she was also just a regular
ultimate at some point in the video game
damn all right let me spend the next
hour looting in here then not that i
feel like i did it that thoroughly
anyway i think i'll be fine
who's that show your [ __ ] face you
coward hello
so these ones are like sort of like
vampires
they're not lichens they're thinner and
they're um
right
i feel like you should have been dead
god i'm so wasteful with the handgun
the way they're animated is fantastic
the animation in this game in general
the mocap is [ __ ]
brilliant because it makes combat more
interesting too because they sway so
much
um okay anyway
oh i missed it hang on where is that
photo of phantom fish
i think i already got that one in any
case
because it wasn't that the one that was
on the far end of the
um of the what's it who's it you know
what i'm talking about the
that little pond that i took the boat
the whole way down to i think i got that
okay uh shall we
just you know have a bit of a look-see
see if we should maybe craft maybe
something
i like an explosive round i could do
another pipe bomb
just in case there's a sniper lama
and then another pipe up i'll just make
it exhaustive shall we
put you down here
you over here
great looks good okay
i'm surprised i didn't get a new weapon
in that stronghold though i really would
have thought that i would have but um i
wonder if i
i missed some oh this is where this
comes back out if i missed something in
the main room at the stronghold
where is it i did in the middle there so
realistically i feel like i should go
the whole way back there
and i think that i'm going to do that
see if it works
okay
we're just gonna go say hi to the duke
anyway
before probably the end of the game it's
happening
we're doing it
my lord it's my greatest pleasure to see
you return alive
well thank you that's very kind i was
just thinking of ways to pass the time
i'm going to sell you four crystal
fragments
one large crystal one viviente
the knight a quartz crystal
a crystal skull a perfect crystal skull
a crystal hammer this is a lot and i'm
never selling that bucket lipstick you
can't make me
new weapon no
all right nothing
what am i supposed to do with all this
[ __ ] cash a good deal
if i say something all right i'm gonna
save right here
and i think we're gonna leave this
episode here everyone um
i assume we are just about to finish the
game i am actually after recording gonna
see if i can go back
to get whatever last item it is that i
missed in that red room i won't put you
all through that
um and see if i can look back around and
then we will put
the last piece of my child in an altar
as it were